Each person who entered our therapy clinic
answer a stack of questions
before beginning treatment.
And during my years as a therapist there,
there was one question I always reviewed
before meeting with a new client.
It asked this:
What is your purpose in life?
Defined as a central motivating life aim,
something you're trying to accomplish.
Now, to be fair,
this is a difficult question.
Identifying a single purpose
in life feels really hard.
It also feels consequential.
Many people spend years searching for
and developing their purposes,
and some never find it.
But typically we see responses like this:
to be an engaged parent,
to make meaningful change in my community,
to build a career I'm proud of,
to live for a long time,
just keeping it simple.
But then there was the answer
of one young woman
who I worked with.
Before meeting with her, as I always did,
I flipped to see
how she described her purpose.
And she wrote this:
"To avoid being noticed by other people."
This young woman, a bright, witty,
compassionate high schooler,
decided that her purpose in life
was to make sure that other people
did not know that she existed.
This is the power of social anxiety.
At its core, social anxiety
is about the fear of being rejected.
When we feel socially anxious,
we become hyper-focused
on how we are appearing to others.
We scan the room looking for signs
of threat and disapproval,
signs we might have slipped up
and are at risk for rejection.
And then we seek comfort
in signs of approval,
smiles, head nods, laughs and so on.
And while social anxiety
can be exhausting,
it exists for a reason.
Social anxiety tries
to protect us from rejection,
and it does that by tuning us in
to the nuances and norms
and dynamics of a social group
so we can match our behavior
to fit in with them
and ultimately avoid being rejected.
This is a good thing
because humans are social.
We exist in social groups,
we rely on each other
whether or not we like that,
but also more simply
because rejection is painful.
Take a moment to think
about your own rejection experiences,
however cringeworthy, we all have them.
Maybe you were ghosted after a first date.
Been there.
Maybe you were rejected
from your dream job.
Maybe you were ousted from a friend group.
Rejection's unpleasant.
And social anxiety
tries to protect us from it.
But social anxiety becomes problematic
when it begins to interfere
with the life you want to live.
And this happens
when your fear of rejection
becomes intertwined
with your view of yourself.
When you believe you will be rejected
because you think you have
some inherent flaw,
deficiency or failing of character.
You were ghosted after that first date,
and you believe it's because you were not
lovable or attractive enough.
You were turned down from your dream job,
and you believe it's because you were not
intelligent or competent enough.
You were ousted from that friend group,
and you believe it’s because you were not
interesting or funny enough.
Our fear of rejection is really
a fear of being less than.
Less than we want to be,
less than we think we should be
or less than we believe
society wants us to be.
Now, over time,
this belief system can develop
into social anxiety disorder.
When a person has social anxiety disorder,
they become overly concerned
about other people scrutinizing them,
evaluating them harshly
and ultimately rejecting them.
So much so that they begin to construct
their lives around avoiding rejection.
Because if you can avoid being
noticed by other people,
then those people have fewer data
points on which to reject you.
Now, social anxiety disorder
is one of the most common
mental illnesses in the world.
In the United States alone,
more than 12 percent of Americans
at some point in their lives
will have diagnosable
social anxiety disorder.
That's roughly 40 million people.
Now worldwide, the estimates
are lower, they're four percent,
which in and of itself is interesting.
But based on current population estimates,
four percent of the world
is roughly 300 million people
that will potentially have
social anxiety disorder
at some point in their lifetime.
And despite how prevalent it is,
it's widely misunderstood,
widely misdiagnosed
and often missed entirely.
This is because several myths
about social anxiety pervade our culture.
The first myth is that people
with social anxiety are happier alone.
The stereotype of someone
with social anxiety as a recluse
who'd rather be hiding away
alone in their bedroom
than out interacting with the world.
And this is simply not true.
In research conducted in my lab,
we find that people
with social anxiety disorder
desire strong, healthy,
intimate relationships
to the same degree
as those without mental illness.
And they do socialize,
they’re not robotic aliens.
And when they socialize,
they often enjoy doing so.
In fact, when we ask people
with social anxiety
how happy they are,
they report feeling happier
when they are with other people
than when they're alone.
This is because not all social
interactions are stressful.
Maybe someone feels
socially anxious with friends
but not their romantic partner.
Or they feel anxious with strangers
and acquaintances
but not people like their
neighbors or coworkers.
So even though some
interactions are stressful,
people with social anxiety are not devoid
of the basic desire for human connection.
They just have trouble obtaining it
in certain situations with certain people.
OK, so maybe then people
with social anxiety do socialize,
and when they do, they enjoy it.
But it's with a small,
tight-knit group of people.
And really, social anxiety is about
avoiding the spotlight.
And this is the second myth.
Social anxiety is not necessarily
about a fear of public performance.
While this is true of some people,
other people with social anxiety
find performing in front of others
less anxiety-provoking
than smaller, more intimate conversations,
like when they have to carry
a conversation one on one.
Many people with social anxiety
excel in careers
that are intertwined with social
evaluation and social performance.
Modeling, acting, sports.
In May of 2021,
Naomi Osaka declined to participate
in press conferences of the French Open.
She courageously and preemptively shared
that they exacerbated her social anxiety.
Shortly thereafter, she received a wave
of public backlash and scrutiny.
She goes on to play her first match,
of course, wins,
and then she withdraws
from the French Open.
Many people were perplexed
about how someone
could have social anxiety
and also be the number one ranked
tennis player in the world,
lead a fashion campaign
with Nike -- good choice --
and don the cover of Sports
Illustrated in a swimsuit.
In an interview the year prior
discussing her social anxiety,
Osaka explained:
"On the court is completely different.
I love playing at Arthur Ashe
because it’s the biggest stadium,
and you feel the rumble of the crowd.
You kind of feel like a gladiator
because it’s super-big
and there are so many people
watching your match.
But off the court,
if I was ever thrown into a situation
where I had to speak
in front of 100 people,
I feel like I would start shaking."
There is no one-size-fits-all
profile of social anxiety.
Just like people who are depressed
have different collections of symptoms
at different times for different reasons,
social anxiety looks different
in different people.
And last and maybe
the most problematic myth.
That social anxiety
is fleeting and harmless.
Social anxiety is not just
something you grow out of.
It doesn't magically disappear
when you graduate
middle school or high school.
Without intervention, many people struggle
with social anxiety for years,
for decades.
And social anxiety can influence
every aspect of a person's life.
It can influence the hobbies they choose,
maybe opting for solo activities
like reading, writing,
rather than things like team sports.
It can influence
the careers people pursue.
Maybe opting for careers
with more individual, like computer time,
versus things like sales
or customer service.
And social anxiety could influence
people's everyday lives.
Ricky Williams, star NFL running back,
Heisman-winning running back,
dazzled millions of people
on the football field every week.
And yet he shared that he struggled
with social anxiety, and because of it,
he had difficulty interacting
with teammates,
running everyday errands
where he'd have to interact with people
and even interacting
with his own daughter.
The real tragedy of social anxiety
is that it robs individuals
of their greatest resource:
other people.
Other people help us overcome adversity,
like recovering from illness
or after you bomb a job interview.
Other people help us celebrate milestones
like showing up to the birth of our child
or a wedding or a graduation.
And other people help us overcome loss,
like grieving the death of a loved one.
Our fear of rejection gets in the way
of obtaining and appreciating
the benefits of being accepted,
the benefits of other people.
And in our modern world,
it is harder than ever
to manage social anxiety.
We are more connected today
than any time in human history,
and yet we are lonelier,
more depressed
and more socially anxious than ever.
We have endless tools to socialize,
and yet we're seeing
a decaying social connection.
In a rapid amount of time,
our social structures have been
upended and rewritten.
Technology and social media
have created new standards
for social relationships and interactions:
"Do I post it, do I share it,
do I like it, do I love it?"
We create these bizarre
extensions of ourselves
through curated profiles and now avatars.
We try to make sense of unlimited feedback
from a massive and often
invisible audience.
And the costs of social
blunders are higher.
Things you do and things you say
can live online forever
and subject you to unforgiving scrutiny,
reputation loss and even job loss.
It is a tough time to have social anxiety.
But the world will become more,
not less, connected,
and the influence of technology
and social media will grow,
not shrink.
Now is the time to address social anxiety.
And here's how.
The first and maybe easiest thing
we can do is identify early.
Early detection is critical
because of those who go on
to develop social anxiety disorder,
more than half will have developed it
before their 14th birthday.
More than half.
And social anxiety puts people at risk
for developing other
mental illnesses later on.
Of adults who were diagnosed
with both social anxiety disorder
and a mood disorder like depression,
social anxiety came first
70 percent of the time.
Of adults who were diagnosed
with both social anxiety disorder
and alcohol use disorder,
social anxiety came first.
It was developed first approximately
80 percent of the time.
What these data suggests
is that social anxiety starts early,
and it puts people at risk
for developing other mental illnesses.
But here's the incredible part.
Social anxiety can be reliably
and accurately flagged
by asking just a few simple questions.
Questions like:
"Is your fear of rejection
among one of your worst fears?"
And "Does your fear of rejection
get in the way of doing things
that you'd otherwise
want to be or enjoy doing?"
The cost of asking these questions
is like 30 seconds and zero dollars.
We don't have to create
new infrastructures.
We don't have to upend existing ones.
We can embed early detection programs
into our existing structures
like at schools, new year orientation,
one-on-one counselor meetings
and in primary care settings.
Because if a doctor
can screen for depression,
then she can also screen
for social anxiety.
Early detection
and then appropriately intervening
can significantly alter
the trajectories of young people.
The second thing we can do
is harness our platforms.
One of the benefits of living
in this hyperconnected world
is that a single person
can have a ton of power.
They can use their platforms to create
meaningful and lasting social change.
I mentioned Ricky Williams and Osaka,
who have used their platforms to share
about their social anxiety.
And just from these two people,
we’ve seen a ripple effect.
In response to Osaka's announcement,
Viola Davis,
Oscar, Emmy, Tony-award winning actress,
shared that she struggles
with social anxiety.
A woman whose job it is as an actress
to embody and express
the complexities of people
in very vulnerable and very public ways.
But frankly, these celebrities are not
the poster children for social anxiety.
They're just three
of the millions who suffer,
who were brave enough to talk about it.
And we can do the same with our platforms,
however big or small.
In our schools,
in our workplaces,
in our communities and in our homes.
Because regular, candid and forthcoming
conversations about mental illness
ultimately reduce stigma,
correct harmful myths
and get people the help that they need.
The last thing that we can do
is foster social courage.
Addressing social anxiety is not
about preventing or avoiding rejection.
Addressing social anxiety
is about fostering social courage.
Being socially courageous
means pursuing experiences
and knowing that your chances
of rejection are not zero.
In fact, the chances that you get rejected
at some point in your life,
at some point this year, are high.
And worse, you may be rejected
as a function of who you are.
Things about yourself
that you cannot change.
Where you come from,
what you look like or who you love.
Being socially courageous
means pursuing experiences
because they are important to you
and knowing that the successes
of those pursuits
are not contingent
on your worth as a human being.
Being socially courageous
means knowing your worth
and finding people and social groups
that love and accept that person.
And being socially courageous
means asking that person out,
applying for that job,
speaking up at that meeting or that party
or giving that big talk on that big stage,
knowing that rejection lurks
around the corner.
But the opportunity for growth
and for purpose shines brighter.
A purpose not defined by ensuring
that you go unnoticed in this world,
but a purpose that makes you feel
most alive, most present
and most authentically you.
Thank you.